e l'ho mai pippo siamo tornati nei panni
dell'anatroccolo allora vedo che la
partenza e premi space x starnazzare
come se quasi il menu fosse la parte del
gioco io l'ho premo subito no erano
un'altra parte va beh oddio mi dispiace
rubato gathering e mio questo aia aiuto
c'è un pupazzo di un vabbè non è un
pupazzo è una miniatura di un aeroplano
se io ti metto questo qua in mezzo ai
giocattoli aiuto no titolo mette in
mezzo ai giocatori mettete lo faccio
mettere i mezzi giocatori porca vacca
aspetta avidi che sta facendo finta di
averlo rubato il mio pio x o falsi che
la musica perché io l'ho lasciato lì e
lui se l'è dovuto ricomprare la nuova
poverino mi dispiace perché per la tipa
pensava fosse suo
pensavo che volesse rubare a sono un
genio bellissimo cal ha dubbi dei soliti
occhiali sono quanti sono caduti allora
prima mi dispiace dirlo gli occhiali
nuovo veri nomi mi sento veramente un
pezzente pezzo nè culo no scherzavo sono
qua i tuoi occhi anno mi dispiace
poverino
sei contento bene adesso torna a casa
tua
si teme non mai vista nella natura più
brutta e cattiva
allora ragazzi non penso di essere un
anatra così cattiva cioè io veramente
l'anima il bene mangio le persone quando
di bambini aia ma sia questa roba
questa verità vendola ha detto per
rifugiarsi ma cos'è e cosa fai ma quali
sono le menti chiudere un ragazzo nella
cabina detestate aspetti aspettata come
ho fatto io starnazzato in faccia
scusi mi venne se facendosi fiscali
sotto eh eh eh sono peggiori incubo fai
schifo
e vabbè si è chiuso è la cabina e adesso
sta chiamando la polizia
vabbè mi sembra esagerato ovunque però
va bene non fa niente cosa che ha
chiamato questo valore
c'è un'altra va fuori che mi dà fastidio
a posso fare la spesa quindi per a che
fare la spesa è veramente difficile devo
fare la spesa senza che lei si accorga
che io sto facendo la specie è un casino
ci siamo ragazzi dopo un'ora e mezza
sono uscito a portare tutta la roba che
doveva raccogliere
per fare la spesa esattamente qui nello
stesso punto quindi devo solo metterla
nella cesta messo un ora devo solo
metterla nella impegnative di sporgersi
in avanti e metterla ciò che so
veramente un sacco di tempo raga perché
poi alcune cose non le trovavo e si è
scoperto che stava nella pattumiera tipo
detergente tipo lo spazzolino che è
quello lì però non ci stanno tutte nella
cesta che non ci stanno
non ci possono stare tutte le la gente
troppo piccola la carta igienica e
gigante come faccio a farcela stare via
questo è questo qua perfetto
nulla è più difficile che istruire
un'oca su come si fa la spesa c'è
ragazzi adesso non voglio essere tipo
razzista nei confronti delle oche però
mamma mia è veramente un casino allora
ok per lo spazzolino manca solo la carta
igienica che penso isola mentre non la
mettono elemento le cose da fare va bene
chiudere la negoziante nel garage come
mi scusi i propri e garage per favore
sta qua guarda che la chiudo dentro non
so come fara e vabbé ferma si può aprire
cielo posso aprire
è scema però perso lei aspetta guarda
cosa ciò è stato riccamente io lo mollo
e privato quello chiudo lo chiudo la
chiudo no visto che vedo io no mi sono
chiuso anche io
fa niente mi sono chiuso anche io non so
dove sia possibile
ho capito però chiedo di stare fuori
giornalista aprì la porta qua avere una
bambina grazie
sono uscito
vabbè ma dov'è cosa c'è di così una
specie di corridoio non si apre allo sco
d'arma dai sono entrato in una nuova
zona ragazzi salve buongiorno si
massaggia le gambe lei cosa devo fare
qui fare il bucato con un registro in
paio di calze una pantofola la saponetta
devo fare il bucato eccolo con un regis
e hp scusami eh no vabbè non si possono
vedere queste cose
sono una solo una screanzata ma tanto
non ti potresti raggiungere mai come fai
raggiunge fare il bucato in che senso ha
avuto nell'acqua
lo sapevo ci regole pop e all'aria ce la
fai a bere sotero è difficile devi
fratello tanto senza gli occhi molto
bene alle calze ce l'abbiamo e va bene
un paio tutte pure devo prendere tra
l'altro le calze qua l'importante è
portare la roba fuori tanto una volta
che poi chissenefrega
regis e non lo riprendiamo io ragazzi
come ora sono veramente il number one
comunque cioè nel senso se mi riesce
bene fare una roba nella vita e fare
l'oca non so come mai visto che ci
faccia il giornale vediamo se ne
scoprirà ok
eccolo a l'ho presa l'ho presa me ne
vado di qua non la prenderei mai più
guarda 61 scalzo schifoso
e future
no quello sta andando a chiudere niente
uscire devo uscire per forza perché sono
mi chiude dentro
smettila ragazzi sono mezzo due bestie
hai rotto
fatemi uscire non posso passare
sorpassato di sopra
va bene cose che sono successe no non si
tocca qua non si gioca ok se
teoricamente tutto tranne la sua
pantofola meno che non lo ficchi
direttamente lui dentro la potevi carlo
dentro dentro la bara dalla piscina ma
che fai cup poi puoi andare a fare
quello che stavi facendo fino adesso ma
va alla guerra che pezzo di un'ora mm
se non ti faccio svenire per terra a
posto su tutto cio tutto qua ho tutto
quasi sto pezzente la smettesse di
prenderle rope e se entrasse nella
piscina io riuscirei a finire
ok ok no devo entrare nella piscina
prendi il sapone no il sapone sta qua no
prendi il sapone bravo entra nella
piscina entra e la vicina adesso ce l'ho
fatta un'ora e mezza per fare questa
cosa
un'ora e mezza ci ho messo e col fiocco
cielo soffrendo sa come vuole di come
faccia indossarlo
ah ho capito aspettando secondo me devo
muovermi e fare la finta anatra cioè io
tolgo questa credo è la tolgo e mi metto
al suo posto dorica mente
secondo me funziona e rimango fermo così
vada esatto è bellissimo
sarà immobile mi sono messo io
adesso metterci lo guardano bellissima
secondo mette questa ragazzo che c'è un
casino la bellissima era vera non ero
finta
sono nata propri bella la tua te l'ho
tolta prima erano 6 attenta nuovo
elemento le far sì che qualcuno porti la
rosa da competizione a che cosa a quella
rosa la competizione ok
qual è la nostra competizione ci sta
andando direttamente attenzione cosa che
fa sto scrivendo qualcosa lo anatre ma
ciò che va bene non pensavo stanno
litigando per che gli ha rotto il vaso
va bene nel mentre io faccio questa rosa
far sì che qualcuno poi ha poi proceduto
la competizione va bene allora io gliela
piazza in un vaso qualsiasi magari in
questo qui allora il rapporto gliela
devo portare praticamente a lei lei al
cosa per potare lui ha la rosa la
competizione agli all apporto ha scritto
no anatre ma non si è accorto di averla
spingola porto qua poi lei poter alla
rosa invece che la sua pianta l'ha
capito prendevo spostarle la pianta o
ecco vedi che sta portando sta votando
sta votando
attenzione attenzione dai dai
la confonde sicuro sicuro
[Musica]
eccolo grande e bellissima rosa la
competizione quella complimenti per la
rosa la competizione ragazzi di tanto
sveglio di noi che ce l'abbiamo fatta
ragazzi teoricamente abbiamo fatto tutto
dovremo andare avanti non so che si fa
ad andare avanti qua forse quale per
smantellare di manate dal settore sta
andando lei vai vai a venezia a primi la
strada al futuro grazie anno a meno che
quello che ciao
chissà cosa troverò po dentro a dei
ragazzi spero che l'episodio di oca
simulator vi sia piaciuto a me
tantissimo che questo gioco lo ama come
semplice mi piace iscritte del canale e
schiacciate la campanina per essere
aggiornati sui nuovi video che escono
era come sempre civili a propostio nido
è da ragazzi
[Musica]